Claudia is in Nevada to start off this
hour hi Claudia how are you quick
question so you are the tiebreaker in
our marriage right now my husband I make
combined about 115 thousand a year and
the only that we have is the stupid debt
but we actually do use it quite a bit is
that we owe sixteen thousand roughly on
a travel trailer and we want to pay that
off so we have two girls that I just put
them in horseback riding lessons for the
last month ago each week and it's $50
each week they stay there for five hours
and they actually get hands-on and our
working ranch and they take their
lessons they absolutely look forward to
it every week and so I think it's worth
it if we use it as a line item in our
budget and maybe cut back from somewhere
else
my husband says you're so intense Ruby
does anything until this trailer is paid
off sell the trailer oh you know we use
it so often we really do get a lot of
use out of it well I mean you like the
horse backlash and res lessons better
though my goal do my husband likes the
trailers okay and so you make 150
thousand dollars a year you have sixteen
thousand dollars on the doorway I'm
sorry 150 yes and you have sixteen
thousand dollars out on a toy this
sitting in the back yard that you use a
total of two weekends a year we use it
quite a bit more than that what do you
do on a regular to use it for hunting
trips camping trips how many times a
year there's been a night in that
trailer how many nights here probably
four weeks you're exaggerating
well we go for a week during spring
break we go a couple of weeks in the
summer we do a week for hunting trip in
October that's at a minimum that's being
conservative okay and what is the family
willing to do to get it paid off in
order to keep this toy well I mean I
only work part-time so I don't mind
beefing up my hours any guy
what else is the family willing to do to
get this toy paid off how fast you got
it paid off
oh I mean I'm willing to do whatever it
takes
only because I see so much joy and what
my goals are all faster you're gonna
have it paid off is 16,000 you make 115
how fast do you pay that off probably in
six nights that's good okay if you can
do that and keep the horseback lessons
then then get it done the horseback
lessons are not really moving the needle
here mathematically but what they are a
symptom of is I'm continuing to try to
do all the same old crap I've always
done while I'm justifying keeping a toy
around in my backyard and so you've got
to not do that
so that part your husband's on to
something there okay but the math that
he's attacking he's not is not really
moving anything but I mean you guys
don't need to see the inside of a
restaurant while that trailer is sitting
in your backyard with that dad on it you
really don't and you don't have time to
go on vacation you're working all the
time to get this stupid dope aid off
that's what we're talking about here
that's a lot more than $50 a lot more
it's thousands of dollars that I just
described there so have you have you
stopped your contract contributions to
your retirement usually I can't help you
if you're gonna have but do all this
stuff you call me up about a $50 thing
with horsey riding and you guys are
still going to restaurants and you're
still doing all this other stuff I'm
telling you not to do now you know
better than that don't you absolutely I
do okay that's what your husband's
talking about right
there that stuff right there so stop
your freaking retirement stop going to
restaurants stop going on vacations cut
your life to a bone work your butts off
get the stupid toy paid off or sell it
and the $50 horsey lessons aren't your
problem it's all this other crap that
you're happy but doing is doing it
that's what you get into here Claudia so
you guys do what you want to do I don't
care you're adults but you cut man
don't make the mistake of call me asking
me what to do when you already know when
I tell you to do go do the stuff we're
already telling you do then you don't
have to have these arguments but this is
the deal is is the horsey lesson was the
last straw because your husband has been
observing that y'all are half but doing
all this other stuff and he's had it
with that now I like your husband yeah
and the way he got your attention was he
threatened to take the horsey lessons
away and so keep the horsey lessons and
fix the rest of the crap is what I would
do or sell the stupid butt trailer
everywhere you talked about going they
rent places you can rent a cabin to hunt
you can rent a hotel on vacation you can
do all kinds of stuff without this
trailer in the backyard but if you want
to keep it and you can pay it off in six
months and you're willing to roll up
your sleeves and go do it I would
probably do that if I were you
thanks for the call